in this path that that they're trying to
go down of a man can be a woman and and
you can you can kind of give into these
delusions and you can you can
supplement these these mental illnesses
I mean that's let's be honest that's
what it is even if you ask the person
themselves they'll tell you I'm I'm
mentally ill something's wrong with me
um why do we these days buy into that
why do we say that that's good why are
we teaching children this why are we
sexualizing children
that's the
that's the craziest thing in the world
why is that okay why does anybody that's
that's an able-bodied adult feel like
it's okay to talk about a child's
sexual orientation sexual anything why
is sex and children in the same sentence
it's so mind-boggling to me that that
more people don't say how wrong this is
and so many people attack people who who
come out against it it's pure evil if if
sexualizing children isn't evil Then I
then I don't know what is I mean it's
the purest evil that I that I can think
of
um
in allowing people to to to do this and
allowing people to to main children and
and and
give in to this stuff is is just it's
just wrong it's just flat out wrong it's
it's and a lot of we've been talking
about is Islam and you know things being
allowed and not allowed
and if we truly believe this is the word
of God and we know that this is the word
of God why would you not listen
to what God is telling you you you're
going to hear them and then look the
other way and say okay I'm gonna do what
I want to do it's the most insane thing
in the world to me and I don't think
Earth has a big enough punishment for
people that that decide to do that
yeah and I think uh many people when
they see the the mob attacking a small
group attacking people who come out to
say look leave our children alone
do your thing in your bedroom keep that
over there to yourself but leave our
children alone right which should be
obviously but apparently it's not yeah
apparently it's not yeah I feel like
that should be the most basic obvious
thing you you have a right to defend
yourself you have a right to defend the
people that you love especially
defenseless people yeah speaking about
children and defenseless they don't they
don't know anything they only know what
we tell them and if we tell them right
out the back that it's okay if you want
to be a little girl if you if you're a
boy it's okay it's okay all right yeah
sure if you
it's it's it's so crazy and even when
you hear the the arguments of oh gender
is a is a social construct many things
are a social construct we still abide by
them
this building that we're sitting in at
one point was a social construct we're
still here
why is that an argument I don't
understand if gender is a social
construct it
okay it's true
all right
I don't understand any of the arguments
for this type of uh dysphoria that a lot
of people experience